[Music]
you're exploring an abandoned building
by yourself you feel alone but you're
not alone were you aiming down the hole
no he's come up the stairs and flanking
right now he's looking at me all around
you people are hunting for the same
thing as you
a shot of scab in the brain you had an
ache a I want it your heart is pumping
you begin to hear footsteps and bullets
all around you but all you can do is
wait
one bad move and everything is gone then
come them and after a while your
patience pays off
[Music]
this is escape from tarkov it's as fun
as it is stressful and right now is
blowing up on Twitch
[Music]
I'm not gonna live in this game this
game is pretty sweet I get it
so tarkoff is basically a hardcore
military sim made by russian game studio
battle state games set in a war-torn
fictional Russian city
tarkoff drops you or your squad in a map
filled with enemy players and NPCs you
can either play as a scab entering the
map with nothing to lose or play as a
PMC kidding up with their own gear
either way your goal remains the same
reach one of the maps extraction points
taking down and looting enemies along
the way thar cops origins stemmed from
battle state games studio head Nikita
boyanov and Nikita yep nothing to see
more we enough spent much of his time in
school tinkering with the world's most
beloved games we amend myself and my
friend from from other school we started
to make some modifications for different
games for half-life morrowind for
concerts straight and we made a lot of
progress
we even got invited by a company in
Moscow so let's take part in the game
development production in Russia when it
comes to programming boyanov is
completely self-taught he eventually
found his way to the gaming industry
where he ultimately created battle state
games but the game boyanov wanted to
create at the time was not the military
sin that we all know today my dream is
still intact and it's all about the
making big single-player story driven
open-world game with the cinematics and
stuff but what I always loved in the
games at the time this type of game was
simply too much for boyanov at a six-man
team to take on especially without
outside help of money so they went to
work on another game instead
tarkoff released its closed alpha in
2016 before releasing a more polished
and refined beta in 2017
it was incredibly unforgiving from the
beginning and tarkov is unapologetically
made for hardcore players first of all
the game is for hardcore players even
meat core to hardcore so it's not like
just like you know casual game and
arcade sugar like like some true person
to say this game allows you to customize
your player is an understatement
I've seen the inventory system and that
thinks scares the [ __ ] enemy tarkov scum
ization coupled with its sink-or-swim
gameplay and constant updates garnered a
small but dedicated fanbase
but after the release of patches 0.12
tarkov exploded I dig it
I think patches 0.12 launched at the end
of October and was tarkov some biggest
to date hideouts a new map to noose
kavitha's new guns alterations to the
game's engine they even messed with the
grass tarkov leveled up and soon
everybody wanted to play the new patch
holy [ __ ] that was nice dude let's go
tarkov baby point 12 tarkov has been
popping off on Twitch becoming the most
watched game on the platform over the
last few weeks streamers like xqc
oh he's invincible sumit wake him at the
last chart and talk
well I'm shooting the minute they tell
me to shoot in the legs are just a few
of the many who've been grinding out
tarkov from December 30th to January 5th
players could actually earn in-game
drops by watching tarkov on stream which
naturally pushed the game to the very
top of twitch and terkoz success
trickled down to the streamers who have
been there since the start with a humble
Ozzy benefiting the most it's just for
three bullets if you're listening very
bang-bang-bang during this period
pastila became one of Twitch's biggest
streamers the guy was averaging at least
18,000 viewers even hitting over a
hundred thousand a few times the 83,000
fields of running an ad now is three
hundred and thirty dollars for in three
ads an hour that's $1,000 an hour that
he's insane fans came to the stream for
the items but castilian kept them coming
back with this off-the-wall yet
endearing personality
[Music]
and in good-guy fashion pastila is
giving back to those in need I've teamed
up with Starlight Children's Foundation
together we're actually going to try and
break 1 million dollars in the year 2020
I've removed all my donation links from
my channel I'm no longer wanting to
receive any sort of monetary donations
our community is already raised 26
thousand dollars back during the game
changes in 2019 and we're gonna go hard
at it this year tarkov wasn't made by a
legendary studio like Epic Games nor did
it have the backing of a huge publisher
like EA instead tarkoff has built off a
strong community of players who
championed their game and took it to the
top we do not spend any money from the
PR campaigns like weed we leave and the
secret is very simple this is an
interesting project and we have a lot of
interaction of cooperation with the guy
with the people for Allah who really
loves the game tarkoff put the hardcore
players first and it finally paid off
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages